that there is plenty for you to talk
about at the moment there is there is
like there is literally too much though
that's the problem there is like an
abundance of material to a very real
problematic extent it would be much more
convenient if there was less more
focused stuff coming out of the white
house it is just a firehose of right so
the problem with that is it's well it's
coming at you that fast it's hard to
filter out the stuff that means
something that means nothing that you
can ignore that you must not ignore all
costs it's difficult to regain
perspective when you're just drowning
all the time so that's the scary thing
sometimes is that you want to make sure
that you are not getting distracted by
the smoke bombs coming out of the White
House all the time how do you do that
it's not easy right it's a case-by-case
basis good you want to kind of retain
your ability to be shocked right because
the dangerous thing if we just get
calloused to Oh everything is hell then
then it's too easy not to think that
something is an aberration when it is
like that's the that's the problem with
life there was his response to
Charlottesville is so heinous you want
to make sure that he still has the
capacity to hurt you right does he hurt
you yeah of course I mean yeah
do you actually you actually feel that
when you're writing and thinking and
talking about it definitely if you don't
feel that you've got a real problem
right if you've become so emotionally
anesthetized to palling by any rational
metric statements then like as a
comedian you've got a problem but also
just as a society you're in some real
yeah like it's it's important to Bruce
when you've been hit does he have any
strengths do you think Donald Trump he
definitely has strengths I'm just not
sure that he knows entirely what they
are or is in control of them so
like a strength is that he has these
rhetorical smoke bombs right he has the
power of that bully pulpit he can
distract people very easily I don't know
if he deploys that skill in a way that
is coherent or strategic but I do think
that it can be of use to people that
work with him because like when
everyone's looking at a kind of a clown
car pileup that it's possible to get
things done in the shadows now that's
been difficult at the moment because
there is a whole different level of
right in 18 competence at the heart of
American government at the moment so
there's not able to get as much through
was you would think for a White House
that also controls both houses sometimes
when you're talking about him
you look genuinely concerned to camera
do you think that he represents a
genuine threat to this country well I
guess the sure answers that is yes he's
a threat to this country yeah I kiss
because he's a fundamental threat to the
institutions that this country is built
on in a way that is not usually the case
with a president on this scale right
he's he is taking an axe to some pretty
fundamental parts of American governance
but what he's doing with the State
Department is gonna have ramifications
for years after he has gone right
there's a brain draining government that
it will take generations to recover from
so he is he's delivering quite a blow to
American government
lots of people voted for him you
understand why they did I think well I
mean there's not one reason why right
there's there's a lot of reasons that
people would vote for him some good many
bad
you developed a reputation for making
British politics interesting really yep
so how are you going to do that with the
brexit negotiations well there's I would
argue there's nothing that is not
interesting about the British
negotiations because that is a Joe of
the highest water that it's we've so
we've done multiple pieces on breaks
right we did one just before the vote we
did a quick piece after that particular
decision and then we did a kind of
update for people alongside the snap
election then Teresa may so wisely
called so we I'm trying to get Americans
to understand this not just the scale of
the decision that Britain is made but
also how completely impossible these
negotiations that they're going into are
this is like going into a negotiation
with absolutely no leverage and
pretending that you control everything
do you think there should be a second
referendum well ideally yes because it
seems odd to make a decision based on
information that was at best misleading
see the potential ramifications of that
decision and then be held to what may
have been a misinformed choice now if
people still want it that's fine but I
think if you still want it on the terms
that are being presented to you that's
very different from wanting it on the
terms that were present it to you on the
side of a dumb red bus well it was
stupid it was a stupid thing to do and a
misleading statement and number speaking
about misleading statements yeah how do
you guys approach the issue of and the
accusations around so-called fake news
because your show is very tightly
researched you obviously the laws I'm
making sure your facts are right here as
great news made it harder has it made it
harder yeah harder for you to connect
with people do your jobs oh because you
mean people would just assume we're
lying
I mean I guess to some extent that's a
problem like it's a really it's a really
nonsense dismiss all this fake news term
which is you know what is so enticing
about it I mean we meticulously research
all the stories we do because if we take
some pretty big swings at politicians
and corporations especially and
especially with the corporations right
if we get that wrong it's probably over
for us
realistically now if you're doing a
piece about Philip Morris tobacco and
you get details wrong we're probably
done you're the opposite effect news
well we can't be fake right partly
because of the consequences that would
come with that